[Music]
take a look at this photo
and tell me what's wrong with it if
there is anything wrong with it there's
no [ __ ] there's no wrinkles there's
no bumps or grooves there's no wrinkles
on it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm a fan
of snickers me too i eat like vain stuff
i need veins i need veins on my mouth
what is up with the veins what do you is
that just caramel so it's realistic but
that's probably the way the the
chocolate is drizzled on though like
maybe like the creator's dick so it's
is not throbbing yeah so you wouldn't
like it if this was in the new snickers
i mean i i would i would still eat it of
course i just feel like the inside would
be like marshmallowy it looks like it
would be marshmallow experience wouldn't
be the same because you know when you
pull it out
like you usually feel the grooves along
the lips and that's all smooth so when
you eat the snickers you suck on it you
put a little bit yeah you suck on it
because i like this i put the whole
thing in i go put the whole thing in and
then i go i gently put my lips on it and
i'd slowly drag it out while i twist it
in a circle okay do you wait you wait
till your mascara runs
yeah i put it in my throat and i i try
to touch the back of the phone a couple
times
[Laughter]
jesus christ you gotta test that reflex
dude
i gotta test that reef you guys don't
like snickers like that
how do you guys eat them
yeah this is the way they're supposed to
look right
yeah damn that looks good oh so that is
good i think it's the chocolate drizzle
that's what i like to think like they
have hella veins on it how come that
one's lacking the [ __ ]
throbbing girl you know like the hard
vigorousness of the original
snickers especially when it's foods that
are phallic this one feels a little less
motivated you know whatever somebody
posted that photo of that smooth
snickers and all of a sudden people
started freaking out that snickers was
changing it's like bar and taking out
the dick veins and people like lost
their minds they were i mean look at
bart he was outraged i was like that was
low blood pressure dude
that's snickers
bro yeah so actually
snickers had to respond on twitter to
like calm everyone down and tell them
they're not they're not taking the veins
out like it's just a rumor
i like having corporate corporate
snickers as they're like so was that
just a faulty
a faulty snicker i don't even know if
someone was in some like hoax someone
might have smoothed it out somehow oh my
gosh [ __ ] or something he probably was
just like
veins disappeared you know you always
suck the veins off
what did they flip it the other way
no even the bottom is inside even the
bottom has shapes oh really the bottom
looks like a shoe yeah yeah it looks
like a soul
maybe that's like a snickers ice cream
yeah
hey that's what i thought this is this
ice cream has veins too oh does it oh it
does i [ __ ] love snickers what's that
one that has a marshmallow inside it
marshmallow um
i know you're talking about you do i
don't like that is it blue is it it's
blue it's like mountains or almond joy
or bounty it might be almond joy it's
choco pie was it almond joy the one with
like coconuts yeah
that one's weird a lot of people do not
like that one for sure a lot of people
my dad likes to do like i judge them i
judge them for sure i like that because
i didn't like chocolate growing up so i
ate a payday
payday because that's just [ __ ]
peanut so you like butterfinger i did
like butterfinger because of bart
simpson but that was the only one i
liked isn't that so crazy how effective
that was oh yeah but i i i hated
snickers
bars was the worst one mars is the mars
is the one with the marshmallow but it's
like chocolate marshmallow
or like whatever taffy or whatever is
that funny because doesn't mars like own
all of these like candy bars we were
talking about what's this what about a
rolo
it was like a roast oh i love those i
like rolos what's a nougat
you know people yeah that's true people
keep saying about nougat i think it's
that chewy thing inside like a snake
it's like applesauce
it's um it's made of sugar and honey and
roasted nuts oh so it's like a different
version of like caramel oh it's like a
nutty carrot yeah people keep talking
about nougat [ __ ] i don't know what the
[ __ ] is it
three musketeers yeah i swerve
i'll eat them my favorite hands down is
toblerone toblerone favorite because
that's new kids
you can eat the whole thing yeah each
triangle at a time holy [ __ ] dude those
are you ever like get one of those after
it's been stored too long and it's like
rock hard and you can't you're just
basking when i like him
he's just waiting for a day
six more years
[Laughter]
did you like tootsie rolls yeah nobody
liked it i thought they were okay i
would eat them i would eat them people
in waiting rooms all tootsie rolls is an
example of old-timey candy it's like
chocolate flavored it is very old-timey
yeah it's like great depression grandma
[ __ ] i like abba
they're like so chewy and it's like it's
got like that peanut butter inside does
that work right is that the black and
yellow wrapper yeah yeah yeah i never
ate that [ __ ] i gotta [ __ ] open all
these things i didn't get as a kid did
you ever um
remember eating a specific candy bar
that's no longer around and you're not
even sure if it really existed oh yeah
um
so they call it i think the reese's nut
rages now but it was different than when
i had it as a kid oh it was a different
total like packaging and everything yeah
but i loved that one too because that
straight out peanuts and stuff and it
looked like dookie like you know what
dookie has lumps
you know how dookie has lost it's like
you know the snickers bars make them
look like dicks they made them look like
dookie
oh okay so
okay so it's just like it's like a candy
bar with reese's in it my mom used to
hide them in the fridge in the garage
because she didn't want me to eat them
and then i found a way where i would
because she'd buy things in bulk so i
would eat all the bottom ones and then
fill the bottom up with stuff so on the
wrapper like my mom checked in the
fridge
it looked like it was full until she
wanted one and then she pulled it it was
just like the wrapper
so funny do you guys remember 100 grand
oh yeah
oh yeah so you know like 100 grand and
mr good bar and crackle those were
always in the variety packs or they're
this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah do
they ever have like four
they're full size hundred grand you
never had the full-size hundred grand
i've only gotten a little like halloween
you gotta go searching for that though
you gotta go to like a candy store
bespoke candy place oh like when you go
trick-or-treating and then they give you
the small version of like the crunch
and it's just chocolate with like things
inside like it's like the size of a
shift key
yeah
the old school keyboard here's a
chocolate that i i thought was like a
fever dream because i remember eating it
so much as a kid and then i never saw it
again and i looked it up i was like it's
real it was like nestle crunch but it
was white and it was called the alpine
white whoa i've never
i've never seen that i have never seen
it so it's white chocolate this was only
in the gift shop of like kaiser
[Laughter]
i've never seen that yeah when i was a
kid this is my favorite chocolate that
is kaiser colors
maybe it was just like a collab
whoa
because i remember eating um
i really liked white chocolate cause i
didn't like chocolate
but there was another one
i think it was hershey's white chocolate
but it had like cookie crumbs or
something cookies and cream yeah that is
really great
that's those are mom dude i got so sick
off those i ate them so much man yeah i
love those
yep
these ones right the cookies oh yeah
this is delicious that's not alpine
nestle alpine white
it's very similar but yeah i thought the
cookies and cream one was actually
better do you guys like s'mores like
making like graham crackers with
marshmallows hell yeah dude you know
there's a s'mores shop at the um new
york new york
yeah so in between when you walk on the
bridge from
uh excalibur to [ __ ] new york new
york the upstairs level they have a
s'mores booth you can just they just
make s'mores so they make it for you so
you don't have to drip and get sticky
all over no you they have a s'more
station you make it yourself no they
make it for you they yeah they have a
s'mores booth and then it's a little
overpriced because it's you know yeah
what's the price on that resort fees i
don't know like seventeen dollars
yeah i just looked at the price i'm like
that's a lot it kind of reminds me of
the the peanut butter and jelly
restaurant in a grand central market
have you seen that they have one oh they
have one there's a pb j place yeah
that's it like 25
i don't think anything was under 10
bucks from whatever did you try it is it
good no i didn't try it but you see a
lot of people try and get it ironically
and then you know it's kind of like one
of those spots but it's been open but is
it like does it taste that much more
bomb though compared to making it at
home i can't get myself to like buy one
of those so expensive huh yeah have you
seen those luxurious ass like peanut
butter sandwiches when people use like
artisan [ __ ] bread it's all thick
toast like that thick and then like they
have like
thick ass pieces of fruit inside of the
jam and [ __ ] and everything they make it
artisanal yeah and it's big like the
sandwiches are like [ __ ] a fistful
you know these like giant brioche buns
yeah i don't know it's hard to elevate a
pizza i can't make one on my own i want
to try one at the restaurant deep fried
ones are pretty good if you guys have
deep fry pb js those are pretty fire oh
you know what i just tried recently
that's bomb i found this ice cream shop
and they have a flavor called pb and j
and what they do is they make pb and j
sandwiches and after they're done they
chop it up into tiny pieces
and then they put that into the ice
cream so you know like cookies and cream
ice cream has actual cookies in it it
has actual pb and j in the ice cream and
it looks [ __ ] bomb freaking pretty it
sounds like we're all saying bj
it's video we keep talking about all
these pjs they give you actual pjs
sandwiches they cut up the bj's and
throwing the ice cream
dude all that snickers talk you know
snickers talk
did they ever really make a candy bar
that was intentionally shaped like a
dick they do that in taiwan all of them
are what they do that's how
someone's got a dick that looks like
this cakes and a peanut ice cream yeah
have you seen those
cake no bro you know what i'm talking
about they're they're shaped they're
like danny dicks yeah
and then they're like waffles and it's
just like a regular retail item that
would be in like a non-sex store no
they're like at booths yeah yeah they're
like you could just go to a night market
and then you can get like it's like
going a hot dog on a stick you know but
it's just [ __ ] on a stick yeah they're
like get it to shock all your friends
so it's like the what's it called the
gummy worms remember that you want some
of my worms
it was like it's so cool to shock people
the big giant but now it's just the
adult doing with a dick yeah exactly
that's all they do now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you